i i just remembered a similar thing for
it wasn't for like because we didn't
really have like a dissertation for us
like we had like
three big projects that we had to do and
then
those three projects would go on display
at like the
uh graduation party for our curricula
yeah and uh and one of them for the
course that i was doing was uh i did
like a computer robotics course
and uh have you ever seen like those
robots uh they have them a lot in
america but they're those like robot
arms that are basically like robot
bartenders
oh yeah yeah i've seen it i think it's
an australian invention but basically
it's just this giant
white arm that's programmable and it
pours drinks basically it's just an
automated quality
robot so we had one of those because i
think our university like was the first
to develop it or something
and we had one lying around so we had to
make a program
that used the bartender robot and then
they would use
they would show that off at the
graduation party to actually serve
drinks at the graduation party so we're
like okay that sounds dope
problem was is that it was a group
project never goes well
and second of all i was the only one who
knew how to program
and third of all i sucked at programming
so we made this like whole thing we
planned out this giant thing being like
all right let's do it where you press
this button
you can choose like the amount of shots
that can go into the glass you can
choose the glass size all this [ __ ] and
we're like all right who's gonna program
it yeah the other two looked at me and
they're like
we don't know how to program i was like
all right i guess i'm programming it man
that's what it's it's it's always always
that point where you're like does anyone
not know how to do this
[ __ ] i gotta take responsibilities like
all right i have to i guess i have to
learn javascript from scratch
like sick that this n o n c n c plus
plus
okay yeah i i can do this and uh
so in the end we have to present it
right like kind of like a decision we
have to present in front of the class
but the problem was the only thing that
worked there was one thing that went we
had like
10 different options that you can choose
from none of them work
except for one and that was the one
where you press a button
and it will pour a beer a single beer
that's the most australian thing i've
never heard all day
not even not even like and you and this
is a button you could only press once
once once you once the robot pulled one
beer
that was it the app was dead hell yeah
yeah we passed
somehow i don't [ __ ] know but then
the professor was like so do you want to
have this on the graduation thing we're
just like no
no please i'm not even going to show up
to the graduation i'm too embarrassed
because i'm going to see all these other
amazing projects and just feel like
absolutely
[ __ ] for it but if you want one beer
it's all yours there you go it better be
the best beer of your life
oh it was like some vb [ __ ]